in Germany so I'm going to start for a
few minutes to talk to talk and motivate
this work but I sort of look looking at
some bad things that happen in privacy
in the world and and sort of use that as
a lens to motivate and what we're trying
to do which is the sensitivity sampler
so the goal of that is to automate some
how to make to remove some of the burden
of using differential privacy not with
the goal of replacing anything else but
just maybe another another way to do
things sometimes depending on how slow I
go I'll talk more or less about the
bench line mechanism which is another
piece of work together that complements
the sensitivity sampler and so it's a
it's a function release mechanism and
then hopefully I'll give a plug for a
package that implements these ideas so
for those who don't know Sisyphus is is
a king in Greek mythology for crimes he
did during life he was committed to
pushing a boulder up a hill forever so
to motivate sampling sensitivity and
automating privacy to some extent I
thought it would be interesting to look
at the test tube of privacy in Australia
and to look at bad things that have been
done in Australia kind of like this
combination of cream cheese and yeast
extract okay so I'll talk about two
anecdotes of things that have happened
in the last few years the first one is
probably the most relevant to
differential privacy so this was so this
is in 2016 the federal Department of
Health so healthcare in Australia is
essentially universal everyone uses the
the public health system the the
department under pressure to share data
decided to release 30 years worth of
unit record level data of medical
billing and pharmaceutical prescriptions
for 10% of the population so I'll get
over two million people
so this is extremely sensitive it covers
what what procedures you have what kind
of appointments you have with doctors
also how doctors treat their patients
because you can kind of track a doctor
through this data set and what kind of
prescriptions you have but for some
people their entire lifetime
they had tried to anonymize the data so
they had perturbed dates of of billing
records they had not exactly put doctors
IDs in the data set they had passed them
through one way and an invertible hash
functions and the data set was just put
online as a file you didn't need to
register to get it so so with modern
colleagues Vanessa Teague and Chris
Canaan we we identified doctors in the
data set so we we we reverse these
one-way hash functions which clearly
weren't used properly then we identified
patients in the data set so you can do
things like you know not nothing
groundbreaking for an audience here
looking at looking at the dates that a
mother has had children if the mother
has had several children the dates are
quite unique you can link them to other
other information online and so this is
this is a case of something where maybe
they could have used differential
privacy yeah
just linkage attack yeah - it was a
different kind of a tactic to recover
the doctor IDs for patients it was
linkage yeah so this this is something
you know sharing data maybe you could do
better you know we heard yesterday about
the US Census Bureau trying to share
data with differential privacy so when
we told them about this they took the
data set down and then they introduced
they tabled legislation to criminalize
rear identification in the same in the
same day they announced what the news
came out it it didn't pass but it it
hasn't gone away so it's kind of an
ongoing thing another example from
Australia about privacy isn't different
to privacy but it's the same kind of
thing right the government like many
governments worry that cryptography can
be used by bad people for bad things and
so they they thought about could we
compel companies like Google and Apple
that do business in Australia that I
don't even headquartered there could we
can compel them to know let people have
access to secret data that's encrypted
and despite lots of people pointing out
that this doesn't work piece of maps I
mean cryptography that's called the
backdoor
this was the quote bother then Prime
Minister the laws of mathematics are
very commendable but the only law that
applies in Australia is the law of
Australia so if we legislate that this
is not a backdoor that somehow we're not
breaking maths that it's just a sort of
we're only going to give access to to
private data for some people but not
everyone then that's true also it's not
unfortunately that actually did pass
even though the the legislation wasn't
really worked out very much that there
was very little polishing of it and
it doesn't you might think that
Australians 14 hours away but if you're
in the US Canada UK or New Zealand it
might affect you too did you have a
question Malcolm Turnbull yeah so we go
through Prime Minister's very quickly so
the previous week so we're here talking
about lots of privacy protecting
technologies in the theory of theory of
these things and largely differential
privacy and differential prophecies have
lots of successes right and I think that
there are key ingredients for these
successes and you know I don't need to
read them out they're not surprising to
many of you this view but but still you
know we keep seeing these kinds of
things and this is just one example
there are so many of them but you would
think they would kind of diminish in
time because you have these great great
tools not only do they're not diminish
but we get respectable organizations
like the the UK Office for National
Statistics the equivalent of the US
Census Bureau the Australian Bureau
statistics solving privacy with things
like this the order five safes I mean
has there been extensions with six safes
and seven saves and I can talk more
about that later but I won't right now
you can ask me about it every sorry no
it's not it's not five anonymity that
might be better than this yeah okay
sorry when when are we sort of there
I mean clearly I think we're there
already differential privacy already
works we we've had talks this week about
serious attempts to use the differential
privacy at scale make me maybe maybe
we'll be there you know but as a sort of
tongue-in-cheek maybe we'll be there
when in Australia passes a law
forbidding differential privacy where no
where as you know we've made it and the
question about who would the prime
minister yeah Malcolm Turnbull
let's tongue-in-cheek maybe you know it
would be nice to to aspire for data
scientists and developers to be able to
use differential privacy in a very broad
sense so there are lots of great systems
that enable differential privacy instead
of a restricted restricted analysis job
do Qi yesterday in the panel talked
about someone who are just doing their
analysis and it being differentially
private so sort of think think that I
think that that that's a nice thing to
aspire to as well as lots of great
directions that people are taking now so
in this work we were sort of thinking
what's a pain point that that sometimes
barrier and and one that we sort of
identified is sensitivity bounding
sensitivity and so one of the great
things about all of these wonderful
building blocks these sort of the
periodic table of elements of
differential privacy is we have these
generic mechanisms like Laplace Gaussian
exponential et cetera and they're really
fantastic
you know we've analyzed them already
people can just use them and you just
need to bounce sensitivity in order to
invoke them and I think pretty much
every talk this week mentioned global
sensitivity or sensitivity at some point
I was trying to keep track so what does
that look like I mean many of you know I
know I'm just using my own words I don't
want to pick on anyone else this is this
is we were bounding sensitivity of an
SVM this is not the state-of-the-art way
of doing privacy-preserving SVM's but
it's in a sense for some people and the
audience this would be easy at the time
as a grad student I'm sure I wouldn't
have been able to do it with my
fantastic advisor we leveraged other
things but you know I think that it's
safe to say a lot of people who might
use differential privacy to do something
slightly new might find this kind of
thing hard so this work is is trying to
follow the prime minister's example and
and not use mass so we don't we don't
want to we don't want to say to people
you need to bounce sensitivity and
there's there's lots of related work in
this area and I won't enumerate it but I
just sort of mentioned that some ways
that people tackle these kinds of
problems is they say we'll we'll have a
very general class but not sort of super
super super general of analyses where we
can kind of keep track of sensitivity
for a year and there are lots of systems
like that that are great what we wanted
to do was to sort of think about well
any function that you could privatize
with one of these generic mechanisms
that you need to bounce sensitivity for
we'd like to let people use those
mechanisms without bounding sensitivity
so we want that's the class the classes
are the things that can be you know you
can use your narrative mechanisms for so
what do we get what do we get for this
work well why should you listen to the
rest of the talk we can privatize in
some sense privatize and I'm going to
talk about that blackbox functions so
that they there could be something that
you've written down on paper they could
be something that you don't have source
code for an executable that you can just
run so we we only require Oracle access
so just evaluating functions we don't
require of course sensitivity that's the
point you don't require gradients or
anything like that so one use case is
you don't want you you want to be like
Malcolm Turnbull and you don't want to
do maths another use case could be that
you have a mechanism that that's well
studied someone who's done an excellent
type global sensitivity bound already
that you don't know that the the
software you're using necessarily
matches what has been analyzed so in the
case of the SVM if if I pull up a
standard library for svms is the global
sensitivity that we rebounded is it the
same does it apply to the software I
don't know I don't really know it might
be implemented a little bit differently
so that's another use case for this now
there's a big caveat so we're gonna pay
for this we're going to pay in privacy
so so we're going to get something but
it's not what we would what not
we would typically like okay so you know
and I'll get to that so like many people
I didn't want to go through the
definitions but I as a parent of young
children I don't like getting presents
without batteries in them so for those
at home they can look at the slide more
slowly so but I've just highlighted the
things I just want to mention that often
when you're doing differential privacy
in you're using generic mechanisms
you've got some function that doesn't
preserve privacy it might be the
analysis you want to run it might be
something related to the analysis you
want to run it's taking a database in
its room and it's returning things in
some normed space okay we've heard about
sensitivity a lot this is global
sensitivity it's relative to the norm
and it's also relative to whatever your
relation is on databases and so for
things like puffer fish that we heard
earlier today heard about earlier today
and and Blowfish
you can have different relations or it
could be that the usual one and then
like I've said there are lots of
wonderful really useful building blocks
and differential privacy these like
generic mechanisms that they need to
have this sensitivity measured in order
to guarantee privacy okay so that's the
batteries so they're a kind of I don't
know how to count them there are kind of
two ideas and they're really simple I
think so so basically I'm going to
derive the sensor sensitivity sampler
and kind of improve it as I go and then
I'll say what the result is so the first
idea starts with the definition and it's
it looks a lot like the definition of
pure differential privacy but there's no
there's no I'm not quantum not
quantifying for all databases okay so
I'm just saying fit for any sensitivity
level and for any pair of databases they
might be neighboring I mean I've written
neighboring here they don't really have
to be just any pair of that arm
databases this implication holds okay so
the mechanism is sensitivity Inge is
private when on on a pip you know when
for a pair of databases and
or sensitivity the sensitivity at those
databases sort of instantaneously is
bounded by its level then we have this
uniform over all measurable sets so
different pure differential privacy
condition holding but instantaneously on
the pair of databases okay so might you
might have a mechanism that you know
this doesn't hold for all pairs of
neighboring databases that's okay
just whenever sensitivity has gone up
running the mechanism with that
sensitivity gives me a privacy condition
that's what I'm gonna call sensitivity
in Jews private and they're not
surprisingly most generic mechanisms
that are sensitivity based satisfy this
definition you could refactor the
privacy guarantees for these things to
kind of use this and it's not saying
anything there's not there's no insight
into this okay so Laplace and Gaussian
the target function is the thing you
want to release okay so York Lydian
vectors and there are these mom spaces
for the Bernstein which is what I'll
hopefully get to is a function release
mechanism so it's releasing a function
from some subset into our real valued
functions and there's a there's a norm
on those and for the exponential
mechanism it's a little bit different
it's not the thing you're trying to
release per se it's your score function
so indexed on a database you release a
function from responses to quality
scores right and then the way you main
measure sensitivity is you take a Max or
a soup over absolute differences on all
responses okay
so this definition holds for lots of
mechanisms that's all I'm trying to
point out so if I have a distribution on
data I'm going to talk about where this
distribution comes from later if we have
a distribution I can convert that
implication for private the sensitivity
induced private mechanism I can convert
it into this relation on these two
probabilities right so if I draw
databases
according to P to the n plus 1 so
neighboring databases that are drawn an
idea according to this P then this was
the left hand side of my implication you
know the probability is upper bounded by
by this thing yeah that's nothing okay
that's just the implication written in a
different way now the thing on the left
is something that exists already so this
is yet another definition it's not
particularly new it's called random
differential privacy I've not called
that RDP because there's a more recent
definition that's sometimes called RDP
so random differential privacy gets due
to a group at then at CMU Hall or
another and Wasserman and the idea is to
say we've got randomness in the data now
and it's a little bit like pufferfish in
that sense that the mechanism is life is
likely to hop is likely to have pure DP
randomness with randomness in the data
right so there's there's certainly
randomness in the mechanism in this in
saying epsilon DP and then it's wrapped
around with randomness in the data and
we've got caught some confidence so
there's confidence given by gamma but
also what affects our confidence in this
is the choice of distribution okay so I
haven't said it already
I know I have to talk about that I will
you should suspend disbelief for a
little bit that that's the intuition so
it's like pure DP holds except you know
unlikely databases now you might not
believe in that choice of bed databases
and that's fine
okay so the second thing which is maybe
another idea is to start off by by
looking at what was on the right hand
side okay so we had this is our DP this
is interesting maybe it's some privacy
some kind of privacy guarantee on the
mechanism and then this is something
okay so let's imagine okay we've got our
randomly drawn neighboring databases and
let's measure the sensitivity at those
databases okay and that's another random
variable like the sensitivity random
variable okay and so the thing that we
had on the right hand side is just the
CDF of this thing and sorry if so what
the the first idea is just saying is we
get some confidence level that's given
by the CDF of this ramp of this random
variable okay and so if my goal is to to
not come up with Delta myself I could I
could ask okay maybe
what's the quantile right what's the
quantile of a confidence so instead of
choosing a sensitivity maybe I'm happy
to choose a confidence level I choose
that and then I calculated exact
quantile that's not easier than bounding
sensitivity okay so so this this doesn't
help at all we're just moving things
around we haven't actually solved
anything so this isn't really a good
thing to do per se if you look at the
original paper on random differential
privacy they have some examples where
they they compute this kind of stuff but
it's not you know even for simple
examples it's not this is really easy
you have to choose very nice and
workable distributions in order to do
this kind of thing so that's not we
won't do that what we'll instead do is
we'll estimate quantiles instead of
calculating them exactly so here's the
algorithm so we want a sample iid from
the the sensitivity random variable some
number of samples
lots and lots ok thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands you know
is this an easy thing to do it well
as long as it's easy to sample from your
distribution so you've got to keep that
in mind when you're choosing your
distribution
got a sample from it and as long as you
can eval you evaluate your function as
long as you can calculate a norm if you
can do those three things you can draw
these these samples these observations
from the sensitivity random variable so
we do this we form the empirical CDF and
then we we just invoke the dkw
inequality so it's a like a finite
sample uniform convergence resolved so
it says that you basically have a
uniform confidence band around empirical
CDF that includes the CDF with with high
probability okay so I haven't I haven't
written down what those expressions are
that they're row Prime in Rome you can
you can sort of choose them right it
depends on how many samples you have and
like this picture is supposed to show
what we really like to be able to do is
invert this curve and get get a
sensitivity but what we're instead going
to do is be a little bit pessimistic
we're going to operate at a slightly
higher sensitivity we're gonna maybe
randomize a little bit more than we have
to by sort of imagine there's a
confidence bound band around the step
staircase and so we're going to invert
that slightly higher confidence okay and
inverting the empirical CDF is is really
easy right you just sort sort your
observations you walk along and that's
it so that's super easy to do yep so do
you take the east over deep tribes the
neighboring G primes or you sample Jesus
then look for their neighbors that ended
up in the central so I'm just looking
video slide the device year as the
distance from that when they bring it
since but you're only sample Lewis
amputee supporting Jesus enterprise from
the yeah so the birth which is obviously
potentially problematic yep yes so so
there's no worst-case yeah
so we're not going to get pure DP that's
right so what's the try distribution on
D and D prime you sample D then you
sample a random index then you replace
the point with another random sample yes
yeah yeah all you assume that the
function doesn't care about the order of
data and you just replace the last one
yep
okay so what essentially proven is that
you've got these things that we've
talked about already there's this sort
of free parameter Rohit depends how you
write all of this down
it's either free or not and you need to
take a large number of samples of this
sensitivity around variable you you need
to figure out where you're going to go
in the staircase that's the order
statistic and you just you take that as
your empirical sensitivity estimate if
you run your mechanism with this
estimate you get not pure DP or epsilon
Delta you know we could have done this
represent alter as well there's nothing
special about pure but we don't have it
holding on all pairs of databases it's
not worst case in the database so we
definitely pay something right so it but
it's in somehow like random data so this
is random differential privacy this is
puffer fish kind of thing so okay
there's this being you decide I I don't
I think it needs to be small to believe
in anything releases it needs to be very
small in order to believe anything
that's released from this thing are
there cases where someone would be happy
to run it with with cameras pointer one
maybe I think it depends if are you
doing this once this also depends on
compositions which I'll talk about so
the answer is not necessarily simple I
think it's great it'll be great to hear
from other people what what they think
yes presumably gamma is constrained by
like the runtime for the southland right
you have to sample enough times really
estimate yeah for him to be big yes so
right so you could choose your n you're
bad so this is a sub next slide you
might decide there's a gamma you you
like or one minus gamma in terms of
confidence
you might instead decide that you can't
you have a certain amount of time or you
might sort of decide both and then you
use those things to set things to set
the other parameters and we can solve
for all of these things and we've done
that this row parameter which comes from
the sort of the confidence from dkw uses
this lambda W function it's a standard
special function and I quote I put
special in quotes possessive word the
words would cancel out it's it's
implemented in most libraries of special
functions it's a multi valued function
but we're we're always the second branch
it's always real valued it's in the
range we want there there's a recent
bound on the second branch from chapter
Georgio that you can use to sort of
understand how the amount of effort
grows with the confidence that you want
that you might want so these kinds of
questions could inform your choices
about about m et cetera et cetera now
depending on your distribution if your
distribution is data independent which
might not which main may be good maybe
not may not be good you could do the
sampling offline before data arrives so
and it's also the sampling is you can do
in parallel so so for some analyses that
might be complicated to analyze manually
or analytically you might be able to run
them quickly and gather lots and lots
and lots of samples if you can't
obviously it's it's it's a problem
because gamma won't be very small this
is here I've plotted the not
sufficiently larger range I should have
gone below that I made this two years
ago and I would have to open things up
again and I didn't but I've got other
plots later with smaller gammas so you
can see 4.05 you need sort of a bit over
a thousand vaguely remember 0.01 it's
something like several thousand
maybe ten thousand or something like
that and it but it grows pretty quickly
and know the log scale so don't be
fooled okay so one thing you can do is
just like with pure DP or all of your
fake you know whatever your favorite
notion of differential prophecy is you
can you can make trade-offs right
between privacy and accuracy so for this
you can you can change your gamma and
and essentially operate at the different
quantum level so you can have sort of
better sensitivity if you're willing to
have a different gamma of course just
like with random differential privacy
but before any sensitivity sampling
that's not new to this and it depict
that it depends on how many samples you
want to do so now let's talk about
random differential privacy a little bit
because I think you can only suspend
disbelief for so long so this is my
attempt to sort of think of pros and
cons and you know this is really like I
don't write if people don't like it
that's fine I don't really have a horse
in the game it's you know I'm never P or
D P is my first true love that's never
going away so the first thing the first
thing to do is that to talk about that
the distribution like what could you
what could you use for the distribution
do any of these make sense
maybe for some cases I think maybe for
some cases definitely not for others or
maybe not for many so one is to sort of
choose something non informative like
uniform or Gaussian or something like
that okay you can do that you know it
might not be convincing it really
depends on the domain of your data the
advantage of that though is you can run
things at a time and do lots and lots of
samples so that's happy so you could
analyze your your function that you need
sensitivity for a lot or you could use
some prior knowledge from somewhere else
okay but not data dependent or you could
fit a density privately using some of
your privacy budget and then you could
use the rest of your privacy budget
since its sensitivity sampling from this
private density if the if you believe
the private density is close to the real
one you have like a misspecified
distribution that you're doing RDP on
now
random differential privacy on one
distribution does give you some kind of
random differential privacy on a closed
distribution but it you want to be very
close to sort of say it's it's the same
thing so those are some you know very
very preliminary thoughts I mean
preliminary --is of two years ago I
haven't thought I haven't sort of met
thought a lot about it since then but
you know definitely happy to discuss in
in the the derivation I sort of imagined
the databases were iid nothing really
required that what we required for dkw
was that the observations of the
sensitivity random variable were
independent that's that's we need that
for dkw so the within database database
could could not be into it doesn't have
to be independent but between they
should be okay we could also change the
neighboring relation and sort of do
something like or maybe not blowfish but
maybe puffer fish to sort of recover
something like that so I've got this
thing and I don't know that I'm going to
go through all of it
now but you know I think if you can do
pure DP of course you should like no one
should tell you otherwise if but there
are situations where you might not be
able to or might not want to approximate
DP you know is is pure DP except for
unlikely responses if you're willing to
take that gamble it depends on your
Delta of course random DP you know you
have P ODP holding except for unlikely
databases I can imagine in some cases
some people might be willing to do that
but a note really depends on your
distribution in your Gamma
what are the samples you can stick that
when do you think it's good mmm
I mean I think if you're able to get
gamma down very small and you're using a
distribution that you believe in so
you're doing something you've got you've
got a data set that where we've had many
other data sets before they're very
similar we've got something slightly
different
so I might believe in the distribution
I'm using for an MDP gamma is small if I
don't need to use the data set a lot and
I'm not worried about composition
between different analyses I might so
there's lots of ifs right but but maybe
in that when when all of those
conditions are satisfied I might be okay
with it
I think it's also rather someone to use
random DP than no DP at all so that's
another way to look at it from the other
end but I don't that's a bit defeatists
maybe but again I think of Sisyphus and
it's like all don't use DP when they
should so on composition so this is a
good point that I do want to make so
approximate DP and some more recent
notions like Reni ADP compose well so as
far as I know it's not known that random
DP does that in the original paper they
just use the Union bound and it's
terrible it's like it's like pure DP now
you need combat I sort of the way I
think about composition you need it for
two maybe two things maybe they're the
same thing on the road but you need it
for certainly two things you needed to
develop our analyses on you know
complicated algorithms that aren't just
basic building blocks and you also need
it to track privacy budget over time
like when you run lots of analyses on
the same data
so with with the sensitivity sample you
don't necessarily need composition to
understand the privacy of a one
complicated analysis you can just put it
all in the black box in estimated
sensitivity you do need you do need
composition there over time so maybe in
there there's there's some use case may
be main like they're not adaptive case
composite composition them an adapter
yes yes yes you're asking queries based
on the answers oh yeah no absolutely so
if I'm I'm in the the okay the
Australian Bureau of Statistics a and
I'm doing some analysis analysis and
then in my department and then I share
it with someone else and I should have
been private but it's like it's okay
we're gonna make some decisions we're
gonna chain a bit and then pull it back
in I would regard those as two separate
things it's really your threat model so
it really comes down to your threat
model why are you being adaptive but
that's a that's a better way to say it
you know
okay so I'll continue if okay
[Music]
tenants so very quickly some toy
empirical things but yes would that leak
privacy um it depends on your
distribution that you chose if it's data
dependent and you didn't do anything to
sanitize the distribution that you were
drawing from yes there would be concerns
if it if it was differentially private
or just not data dependent then there
wouldn't be any concerns it you know it
depends on them it depends on your
function but that's part of what is made
public so the short answer is no not
then how thought about it but I'm sure
you could do it wrong and yet so this is
just some toy experiments within sem a
relatively small data set
we've been optimistic about the
distribution generating the actual data
and then the one with that we're using
on the left it's just looking at
sensitivity sort of how bad our global
analysis was so I know that I'm
competing with myself here so it's not
really fair but it's pretty bad he's
some sort of accuracy results so this
was like varying dimension this is this
is for dimension 2 so very toy and and
you can see ok this is epsilon budgets
that are incredibly small but like the
sort of slightly bigger ones you can see
some difference although gamma isn't
that small here so I think this camera
is probably too big for almost anything
I have other results in the slides with
much smaller gammas but I don't know if
I'll get to show them but I can show you
afterwards so that's the sensitivity
sample for a few minutes all I'll
quickly talk about a way to do private
function release Mathew on Monday talked
about a more recent way in any did site
so at this um so I'm his way is probably
better my way is just in another way
well I'm
giving excuses for not comparing my
other excuses that ours was 2017 and so
somehow that gets me off the hook for
comparing things but other I don't know
so what we're trying to do in in this
work which come in a sense compliments
because it's another sensitivity based
mechanism is we want to release
functions okay and so we want to release
functions with bounded data in some
dimension this could be like a learning
algorithm we and we want to do something
fairly simple that doesn't require a lot
of information we don't want to have
many restrictions on the functions that
we can privatize so it's a similar kind
of thinking it's a sensitivity sampler
so we don't assume these functions are
separable or anything in the data that
can really be anything to get utility
bounds we need to assume some smoothness
though but for privacy we don't need to
assume anything so we have some
parameters and this is the algorithm we
evaluate we get our non private function
okay so we're unlearning
so G is the thing we want to release we
we have agreed it doesn't necessarily
have to be a sort of even grid you could
you could somehow be clever and adapt
and we weren't we haven't been clever so
far you just have a regular grid on the
domain and so you can imagine already as
the domain growth as the dimension grows
you're in trouble so so actually the
thing we do assume as the dimension
isn't too big we we run we essentially
evaluate this and get and get
coefficients in a basis which actually
just involves evaluating the functions
so when I say approximator I actually
just mean evaluate now then we have
perturb these coefficients by Laplace
but you could use something else doesn't
have to be laplace then you just release
them in the nets it for the
privatization bit and then to actually
use this approximate function to make
predictions if it's a classifier or to a
you know evaluate it you need the basis
functions that we're that we
these coefficients are relative to the
basis functions aren't data dependent
and so you just the value you just take
a linear combination of the perturbed
coefficients with the basis functions
what I haven't said is what are the
basis functions that's the next slide
this is the algorithm the basis
functions so they're they're Bernstein
polynomials they come about in the
Weierstrass theorem for you know
uniformly approximating continuous
functions they're very neat they're
basically like the bun that they're
essentially the the binomial PMF so that
that's what they are so they're they
have some degree that you can choose and
there are there are k plus one of them
the coefficients in this basis is just
the evaluations which is really nice
it's really easy to do and the bench
none operator which is how to
reconstruct the function in this basis
is just this linear combination of these
basis functions so this is like an
expectation so taking a binomial random
variable and then taking the expectation
essentially with respect to that and the
variable of G but where the distribution
of the binomial variable does depend on
the the test point essentially this is a
picture of the blue a blue Bernstein
approximation to some function don't
make up so you get privacy you get you
get pure DP if you know sensitivity you
get utility - you get it by a
concentration is art by proshare so the
thing to sort of notice is that we've
got a convex combination so the convex
combination suppose we have a
distribution and so we're using that and
we're also just using the Weierstrass
theorem because the approximation within
the basis is close to the original thing
that's just that and depending on what
you assume about smoothness of your
original function that that is in
private you get some kind of utility and
it doesn't scale that nicely dimension
so that that's the short quick summary
of the bench time mechanism so let me
show you putting the burn time mechanism
and the sensitivity sampler together I
was happy when I heard John duty
yesterday mentioned doing things in ARP
is ok here is an R it's like as if I
prepared it overnight what a good idea I
wonder if you could do that no it was
prepared before so one of what I'm going
to do is show an example of using using
these things together for the priestly
child kernel regression why did we
choose that because when we were doing
Bernstein we wanted some algorithm where
the function you want to release is
inseparable in the data it's not like a
Sun so this this isn't so easy and at
the time other function release
mechanisms couldn't couldn't do this
kind of thing so bench 9 can
so what I'll show you is some synthetic
data the the non-private kernel
regression and then you'll see you'll
see sensitivity sampling happening for
just 500 samples so it's not going to be
very confident and and you'll see the
approximation hopefully work
yes okay there's the synthetic data
there's a non-private kernel regression
and now it's doing sensitivity sampling
now well some some time then it's kind
of not so if I'm watching it but it's
just it doesn't take long there's a
there's private one but if you look if
you look at the parameters they're gamma
is point two so don't do this at home do
not do this like you need gamma much
smaller you need to wait longer you need
larger m okay so it's just for a talk so
okay so very quickly we have implemented
all of the ideas mentioned in an hour
package because it's on cran this is all
if you have an internet connection and
are this all you need to do use it and
then you can write things now it's not
it's missing lots of things it's not on
you know quite there yet you know be
great to improve it if anyone wants to
work on it together that would be
awesome
so that sort of the talk just to
summarize when I talked about while
differential privacy is is fantastic and
it's had sort of incredible successes we
still are seeing kind of these crazy
things happen in privacy right and it's
not just breaches it's also crazy
solutions like people still don't know
differential privacy it's just crazy and
I don't think that it's necessarily
something deficient in privacy but it's
something to think about anyway it's
something to kind of look at every now
and then I talked about the sensitivity
sampler which is maybe has some use
cases sometimes and and it lets you
avoid bounding global sensitivity when
it's hard to do a way you don't trust
your implementation okay I talked
extremely quickly about the bench and
our mechanism for private function
released as well thanks
[Applause]
time for our question until
yeah in a way
bounding the type of functions you
trying to estimate also in a way
founding the the sensitivity of the data
because you started by by mentioning the
fact that we sometimes don't know what
is the original sensitivity of the data
so we don't have to calibrate them no
it's excetera
but you have an estimation here about
the data because you have an assumption
about later because you have an
assumption about what type of functions
you need it can't be a crazy data it can
be a function going crazy so isn't it
possible to just kid the founder the
sensitivity somewhere in the function
but it's it's again it's going back to
the issue of how comes how much can we
found there since the view of the data
so I missed the beginning of the
question but I think I got the gist of
it but apologies if I'm not answering
directly I think that since you know
pure DP is a it does involve data right
I mean the sensitivity involves they'd a
bit in the sense you avoid using it you
avoid being data dependent because you
bounce sensitivity worst case overall
all day databases and so that's that's
why pure DP is such a strong privacy
guaranteeing because you don't you know
it doesn't matter what your data set is
it doesn't matter what exhilarate
information you have you know it's great
that's why it's so powerful but of
course you know you're the data set that
you really have might not be worst case
and in a sense maybe you could say idea
ideas are like smooth sensitivity and
local sensitivity and things like that
it's a way of exploiting this idea
things like random differential privacy
and and puffer fish etc you know you're
you're definitely relaxing your your
privacy guarantee and you're you're
making an assumption that you know
something about where the data is coming
from so you could be misspecified
and you might not have a good privacy
guarantee if you if you use this and and
it is about the sensitivity because
we're we're bounding sensitivity
using some assumption so you so you
arrive but it it's not it's not leaking
I mean the sensitivity itself is what's
leaking things that's running the
mechanism with insufficient sensitivity
so it's kind of when you get into
trouble thank our speaker game
[Applause]